[Music]
okay welcome back to off the record
where we talk about
whatever we want okay we got some
motorcycle boys you a motorcycle boy
i got you know yeah i did i was like i
did a movie called biker boys
and then oh [ __ ] we all got a license
and we've been riding so wait is it the
movie with uh
tim allen and um it's wild hogs that's
why wild hogs okay
just like just a movie derek luke and a
bunch of lawrence fisher
lauren's fish burners in it yeah yeah
yeah a lot of us well you're a biker boy
i'm a biker
oh yeah how's old larry what's he like
he's cool
larry fraser he's actually cool guy he
he rides like in real life a bmw
bike you know he's one of those cops can
you um
tell us about uh hollywood secrets no
okay without naming any names can you oh
please dante because
when the cameras are you have so many
good hollywood secrets sorry sometimes
we all should pitch story but not
where's this patreon you could change
the names of people man oh my god
there's like there's always those things
you kind of see that you're just not
supposed to talk about have you ever
i've ever made out with another dude
that's an actor
i play gay that's not it's not on set
not in a scene
no no no no that's not really hollywood
that's just you know you ever practice a
lot like
yeah how do you practice being gay when
i when i was doing when i was doing this
movie called but i'm a cheerleader me
and this dude kid pardo we had to
do it we have to kiss each other we're
both straight that's a gay film like
straight up like
passionate kids yeah we do passionately
i [ __ ] love you today bro
so yeah so like but the the directors
get that's a gay set it's like
it was but i'm sure it was like a cult
classic gay film and so we never we
figured let's save the first kiss
for the film like why not let's give
each other dabs like like this like hell
yeah bro all right we're gonna do it
like that and then you do it all right
now what happened was we
when we did before that we shook hands
so let's go and then but before that we
were like how are we going to rehearse
this
right yeah how do you rehearse this well
we did
and we were shenanigans we was young
this is before the me too movement
[ __ ] so we got one of the actresses who
was a friend of ours she right in the
middle
you guys had to [ __ ] say what do you
want to do but this is the deal they
were like kids in the [ __ ] trailers
like
how are you gonna read the scene and
basically look i'm gonna make out with
you
and kip's gonna watch and then kid's
gonna make out with you and i'm gonna
watch it we're gonna like study
each other you had a three-way kiss
it was just silly but then that was it
but then when we got on to it we just
went up how old were you guys i had to
be early 20s
you guys just wanted to make out with
the girl huh halfway
halfway she i mean she was down what are
you doing when you're watching your
friend make out with this chick you're
just like
i was taking notes i was taking notes
but but what happened when
i was making out with this dude kip like
he's a big dude tall
like six two blonde dude hands do you
feel
like this in your mind you're like okay
we're gonna find out how gay
i am today did you step on his feet to
kiss him but what it is like when
i remember we went in and it was live
how long was the kiss for it was a
[ __ ] long ass because this dude
shoved his tongue down
and the director was like again he's
like okay there's a tree bam i was like
i was like trying to finesse it you know
what i'm saying like i'm trying i'm a
finessing kisser like
you trying to fall over yeah my dude was
like
manhandling the [ __ ] out of me boom like
a goddamn and i was like damn dude you
[ __ ]
calm down yeah
what the [ __ ] are you doing to women if
you [ __ ] treat me like this god damn
it i'm trying to be like
maybe he still needed to assert his
masculinity
and be like i'm the man here it was
rough i was like he's
i'm not gay he was wrestling and [ __ ] i
was like damn that's just
he's like i'm not gay but i couldn't
[ __ ] wait to do this with you bro
this thing if you never kissed a guy i
don't know if the other because i got it
no no
this [ __ ] right here the facial hair oh
that [ __ ]
is like i don't know how women do it
because it's like it's like a
sandpaper i also hear they like it
though because that's what they're used
to i don't know dude we came out and
it's like we're all red and [ __ ]
oh god damn y'all [ __ ] women
gotta deal with that [ __ ]
and gay guys gotta deal with that [ __ ]
with each other all the time that's
that's intense this
well what if we had like beards and
mustaches you think it's
nicer it might be softer yeah it's like
kissing a dog right but if you
shave it it's gotta be like kissing the
dolphin oh damn
is the one that's the killer how many
takes did you guys do
we had to do a few tapes a few of them
we can't we made out twice in the movie
for angles or because
do you feel like you guys had chemistry
by the later scenes or
homies but we weren't but by the second
time was it like all right
familiar like i definitely got to the
point where i was like you're over yeah
i'm not gay
like i ain't getting like you gotta you
gotta be true for yourself when you
everyone in their life has to like yeah
make out with another man not make a
remember but questions like
am i getting like you got gay friends
yeah you got to get your answers no
judgment like
but not many people not most of us will
never get that answer did you give them
any notes like hey not so hard
yeah i said dude stop he's all right i'm
inhaling me dude can i we can't
can we just like caress my face a little
bit
he's like no that's how i do it
yeah he was like i'm he was just like i
do it the way i feel good that's a true
actor right there he's like [ __ ]
you must put your girl you girls
[ __ ] with you want to get manhandled
i'm not that kind [ __ ] girl
that's not me did you guys dry up with
the two penises touching no
i don't think i did you wrap your legs
around like this
this is the thing because you know
because i'm a smaller guy yeah i'd have
to be the [ __ ] i don't want to be the
[ __ ]
yeah well you should have all [ __ ]
went back at him dude it's not always up
to you
god damn it this is not it's how it is
she got on top of a chair and [ __ ]
kissed down dude so you're dominance you
know
where where was it in the moment bro you
had your moment you [ __ ] i'm not a
dominating person i like i like you
you're a romance
i like romance damn you getting slammed
into a [ __ ] tree
damn look is it not in the goddamn tree
i pictured people dude i want to see a
scene of this now i'm so
curious i want to see dante get slammed
on a tree and [ __ ] kissed
yeah it's easy when you re-watch that
performance does it make you does it
make you uncomfortable oh you got to see
it no i ain't tripping on that
[Laughter]
this is just art right you're just like
this is art yeah uh no this is what was
the girl's name
it's there somewhere but i don't know if
they got arson because it's really
hey you handled it very good though it's
like for the reunion we'll do it again
you're a real professor you gotta handle
it i feel like some dudes wouldn't even
be like nah bro i don't wanna talk about
this [ __ ] like some people just get
really crazy about it i mean what's more
masculine than a dude
that's like yeah you could see me
[ __ ] kiss another dude but for real
and he has no shame in the game yeah and
he's like yeah i wanted to check if i
was gay or not and i'm not
and that's like that's hella honest what
i'm saying is most dudes they
won't even be cut like they wouldn't
even want to talk about this
ain't that big a deal it's just my
[ __ ] acting we make a big deal
because we're idiots that's the problem
yeah and because of our friends growing
up and the way that we were raised with
all that [ __ ]
but now that actually generations they
all they are lead generation awesome
no they shame you if you're not gay
they're like you won't kiss a dude
you never kiss your best friend doesn't
matter what you're weird yeah it's like
what's wrong with you
i mean yeah it's much more fluid now
they they understand the spectrum they
understand the spectrum they understand
that there is a spectrum
we didn't know there was a special
thought it's just homophobia back then
yeah
flip the switch my dad's don't even hug
me yeah that's see because he's too gay
he's my dad like putting his arm over my
shoulder it's like this much straighter
all right
but that's to see when people are chew
like that he's all like i don't want my
gay son to get too horny
we know some dudes who are super
homophobic and our favorite thing to do
is just to
you know give him [ __ ] about it because
he's so like brian gay dog
and it's like and then you obviously
just feel like that's hella gay all day
yeah like bro
why are you being like that just stop
being there yeah either we'll cut a
popsicle with a fork and knife
is gay yeah
american beauty yeah with kevin spacey
yeah but the guy the next door
the neighbor the dad yeah he's hella
military hella crazy
just thinking about that that's what i
mean you know that's hella gay i'm not
that gay i'm like
then then why are you tripping yeah
chill
what is that it's like i always trip
about people have to trip on gabe
because i'm like you know like ricky
martin all those constant weights guys
like if this is a deal you're never
gonna sleep with that guy
yeah you will never be in the bed of
that dude like why do you even
why is it trippy that's so true yeah
you're never gonna have sex with that
dude so why are you pissed off even if
you were gay he doesn't want to [ __ ] you
even if he's working the tennis team's
never gonna [ __ ] with him i think you
are bro ricky martin's gonna [ __ ] you
tripping
out on something that you're never gonna
touch that penis
yeah there's like there's like guys i
have the pleasure to touch that people
they look like nobody wants to touch
them but they're so afraid that a gay
guy
is gonna come on to them yeah like no
dude want your funky ass
you could be on 90 day fiance and not in
a good way
and there's a nine-day fiancee some of
them are crazy looking
yeah that was that was the point of the
construction of the joke i'm sorry
today's video is brought to you by warby
porker all right man you know one of the
things that i love doing is
online shopping right but the problem is
i like to try things on so that makes me
really shy away
from buying clothes jewelry glasses
because i might like the design but a
lot of the times it never
shows up and looks like what it's
supposed to look like
and sometimes you want to compare a
couple of them you do thank goodness
warby parker is here to solve that
problem with glasses
yeah they're dedicated to providing
exceptional eye care service
not only online but also in the store
wherever you go i've been seeing warby
parker stores pop up all over the place
and they can do everything from
eyeglasses to sunglasses
eye exams and even contact lenses and
they have
eyeglasses including a prescription
starting at 95 bucks
in the home try on kit it's actually
pretty pretty easy and you go ahead take
a little quiz
so they know who you are your needs are
whatever whatever right
and then you go ahead and pick your top
five favorite i personally did some
sunglasses
because i want to look cool and i don't
really need glasses glasses
so they sent me that five and i got to
try them all on and i was like man
i love it i look cool in all five but i
chose my two favorite ones
and i sent it all back for free and then
they sent me two
brand new ones that's dope so if you
like the ease of online shopping
but you also like the convenience of
being able to try things on
maybe give this a try it's warby
parker's free try
at home kit and you can try on five
pairs of glasses
for free they ship it to you and then
even the return shipping is also prepaid
so there's nothing out of your pocket it
comes to you for free you try it on for
all five of them
see which ones you like you can buy and
keep the ones that you
want send the ones that you don't
there's no obligation at all which is
super cool
go to warbyparker.com off the record to
try on
five glasses for free on warby parker uh
but yeah man no that's wild that's wild
i love how we were all growing up with
all of that together in the same
generation
because yeah i don't i never will forget
getting called
like the f word all the time and like
like everyone
trying to make you gay for whatever you
were doing but also the way that the
word was used to
was it was like not just literally
homosexual right it meant like so many
different things
you're a piece of [ __ ] like you're a
[ __ ] scumbag or even like being like
a party pooper like oh you want to go
watch movies with us
you're that f word you know it's just
like why are you being such a downer
right now but the fact that we were able
to change
like we like we all know like don't say
that no more it makes me go you know we
are
people could change [ __ ] cancer
culture stop it like just because
someone did one thing
don't mean that's them for their whole
life dude we can't change we as the
culture stop using that word
like for real anymore but it was it was
serious because i remember
um watching news and whatever like gay
dudes will get
beat up just for being gay like they'll
be walking around and then guys would
pull over
and then start beating their ass i mean
matthew shepard right wasn't that the
guy who got
um he like got dragged or something like
that or he got put up against the fence
and they beat him to death
for being gay and what the saddest part
is now that we have all this like
research and understanding of
homosexuality or whatever
that guys that were doing the beating
were probably
super gay right and they were they were
projecting they were
intense about it you're probably gay
because there's so much why is it
what does it matter to you because the
regular people circle you know
you're like so far on this spectrum
you're like over here
oh my god they thought it was a spectrum
like this like no [ __ ]
that's like flat earth thinkers you know
i mean like this [ __ ] wears like this
and i can't you know we grew up in l.a
so i'm always like
you know when i drive on i live in
beverly west hollywood's right there
which is a gay part of
l.a um that's like they call boys town
where the strip is right there
now you think if i was gay anywhere else
in the country i'd be running to [ __ ]
get to west hollywood or san francisco
that's like the safe zone because you're
like i don't want to stay where the [ __ ]
is like
you these guys are just you're gay can
you be free it's like disneyland for gay
people like
oh yeah i wouldn't if you're holding
hands with a chick in west hollywood
everyone's like what the [ __ ] are you
doing
in west hollywood he's one of the only
straight employees and he says that he
gets straight shamed
of course boston he gets bullied bad for
being straight
it's the dominant culture they call him
the f-word
when you're driving around l.a and you
kind of stop an intersection like san
vicente and santa monica right
you're gay we're all gay i said look at
the car next year the people are looking
at us right now
like look at these two look at that oh
yeah they're cute they're gay like we're
cave for that moment like understand
that that's what it is like
and it's you're cool you're not mean
you're really gay but like
you're so what you're saying is uh
getting this is a regional thing
not regional it's a street
perception of someone else being gay is
just their perception
like you sometimes at moments and it's
actually
because of the region because that's
their perception because of the region
in the moment right so they expect so
it's like if i'm walking in west
hollywood doing some shopping you're
like you're just getting like i
shouldn't be surprised if a dude hits on
me right now
because they think you're gay because
it's like oh yeah he's
one of our culture possibly i was in a
gay club in west hollywood and the whole
time i was like i'm not gay i'm not
i'm not gay i'm not gay and they're like
yo that guy's gay bro
that dude is gay hey 50 of the fans here
probably still think i'm gay sick
why why why because you guys [ __ ]
script writing oh
man you guys are you kept him and
lauren's always doing gay scenes
hey you know what i'm gay yeah nice
hey it is pride month so shout out yeah
is it yeah yeah june oh yeah all of june
yeah
it is it is pretty different though
because um like i'm
different as in like how quick the
perception and
how much people accept
the whole concept and everything because
i remember like
in the 90s or even in the early 2000s
right um
it was something that existed but then a
lot of family members would just be like
oh no we don't have no gay in a family
that shouldn't
doesn't exist or whatever and i'm like i
don't think it works like that guys i
think
like i don't think it's like a i don't
know
man that's kind of touchy subjects right
like i'm not gay so i wouldn't know but
i'm sure a lot of the older generation
think like it's a perversion or like you
choose to be it or whatever they
they're like you know they just want to
go out there and suck each other's dicks
all day
and i'm all like how would you know you
don't even you never even had a
conversation with these people
why you make that [ __ ] up you know you
know my ignorance
my ignorance in high school wasn't even
about like the sexuality of it like um
because i liked dancing in high school
but i didn't do it because i thought it
would
be gay um dancing would make you gay
yeah it was like a very
not necessarily like make you but the
perception of you right you're [ __ ]
popular very very
did you think you're gonna go like this
and then start sucking dick and [ __ ]
b-boy b-boy was that like you could
dance
yeah b-boy was really cool but like if
you didn't have like a strong culture at
your school or something like that then
it was hard to find a pocket or get into
it you know what i mean um so like
it was uh it was just something that i i
tried to avoid and
that was just a thing and then going to
college and like finding and joining
dance teams
like if i didn't have that i probably
would have been like an ignorant naive
person
until like society changed me through
like social media cancellation or
something like that you know what i'm
saying but like
through dance and obviously the comfort
of like discovering just like
i guess a human experience in general
like that fixed it for me you know what
i'm saying like being exposed to it such
like a
and you know there was even feminine
choreography that we would always like
you know learn or in training and stuff
like that and those things were like so
so uh different for me in the beginning
and now it's just like so normal it's
like so accepted so normally
yeah once i saw the christopher walken
music video weapon of choice oh it
killed it
i was like dancing is the coolest
[ __ ] thing a dude can do chris
walking kill down he
can dude that [ __ ] can dance
like like crazy but
when we me and my brothers are b boys in
the 80s and then what's a b-boy
pregnancy breakdancing breaker but you
know it's still even though it's like
was more masculine of a dance there's
still the jokes of like you're just
gonna dance battle each other sounds
super stupid you might have the hard
line was weird though it was like
oh you play tennis you're you know like
this
it's just like whatever you play soccer
it's just like
how things are categorized it's just so
[ __ ] yeah even
even pop groups right it's like pop
groups who get a lot of women
were called gay yeah it's like why why
did
why did we think they were because there
was always the one gay guy in the group
yeah no i don't know they're they're
they're swimming in women
and then people are calling them gay
isn't that stupid as [ __ ]
well they're talking [ __ ] yeah they're
just talking [ __ ] but they're like
yeah i don't know because you know what
i'm saying that pop group that always
has that
androgynous teenage boy is that it's
that era of your life where
everyone is questioning their sexuality
that's that's the that's the
tone that they're always you know bts
now like it's right in the androgyny
that's what it's about but i think when
i was people we ended up getting
scholarships and started studying
ballet at san francisco ballet company
wow so we went from like baggies to
tights and it was
crazy were you wearing like a leotard we
all went you had to wear them just white
tights on the bottom it was it was when
guys do ballet do they wear the one
piece swimming
the bottoms oh but then we know we're
like this is kind of weird kind of
whatever then we
started watching mikhail bishkoff stuff
and like that dude's uh
yeah i think tupac did violet right
yeah yeah i mean it's going to be about
grace and stuff but then you want
you know it's like billy elliot it's
kind of like that movie billy billy
those good
yeah i got bullied like a [ __ ]
and i remember
them always calling me the f word and i
made it to the i made it on the
basketball
why though why were they bullying well i
mean on the basketball team and there
was a guy who didn't make it on the
basketball team
and everyone knew that i wasn't very
good at basketball but i was the tallest
[ __ ] in my whole school
so they made it a point to not let me
even sit with the team when we went on
like road games damn you they had a memo
going on like bucks team memo
yeah i was rough because they wanted the
other guy because they were friends
they were friends and then yeah so and i
was just trying out for the basketball
team because the
they wanted me to try out for it and i
sucked
but then um yeah so i had a rough go of
it in middle school because everyone was
saying that
and it's funny when you make a mountain
in your head out of something that
these guys are going you know they're
calling you that word every day or
whatever
and it's funny to to battle that instead
of just go wait why
should i care about what you think of
that but that age is like you're saying
it's so vulnerable you're
blaze you just don't know what the
[ __ ] going on anyway so it's just yeah
it's crazy i can't imagine i mean i was
lucky to have my brothers my whole time
so i have brothers a year older than me
younger than me so we always had
my crew with us so i didn't have to like
be susceptible to like
what the other kids were thinking
because i always had a crook remember
what the [ __ ] they want we got other
friends but if they were
shitty [ __ ] them you got your brothers i
didn't go to school one day in my life
without
one of my siblings with me wow that's
cool so you always felt like a tribe
yeah like you were never by yourself but
it was so long it could be [ __ ] up
yeah well did you want to just beat any
of these kids up oh yeah i was a big
target because i'm a tall
lanky dude and but i'm tall so i look
like somebody
if you were able to push me over or
whatever then it looks cooler or
whatever right but that's when it comes
to jail time i think you gotta beat up
that one kid so bad that everyone else
is close like god damn big ass steve
don't [ __ ] with big ass dude
it took it took like yeah it's funny it
took like my mom always said just walk
away walk away and i was like dude stop
watching [ __ ] oprah
okay walk away does not work i'm going
to talk to somebody else
yeah some of those youtube videos with
the kids these three little the same
things like the big dude and they're all
these like three friends like always
picking on this
one guy and they were videotaping it and
the guy was quiet and then the guy
finally
freaked out and grabbed one of the kids
and slammed them oh yes broke his knees
like you broke my knee
but it was like what the [ __ ] you were
just spitting on this kid and you guys
were all [ __ ] kicking him and [ __ ]
and
he looks like a real timid little kid
until you [ __ ]
poke the bear too much that's right what
do you tell what do you tell your kid
like which kid is yours why are you
killing the kid that got his knee broken
you just team up with uh friends that
got bullied by the same guy
and then um one time during uh recess
uh my friend went behind and he got on
like all fours
and and i pushed him as hard as i could
and he fell behind and tumbled back and
started crying
and he never messed with us again that's
what he gets
you're like a gang leader joe's like
this is what we're going to do he's an
organizer
after nutrition
at recess we were in third grade dude
like fourth grade yeah
do
you